you played baseball for is it ten teams
idea of spring training I played in five
games played for ten teams it all in one
day spring training a couple weeks ago
yeah all one day Oh what day and as a
little charity fundraiser as a charity
fundraiser it's a cool thing to do and
you look pretty good out there
well the only thing is you always have a
in your mind's eye a different picture
of how you look in the uniform and
[Applause]
walking back to the Doug
that's just me having a seizure but yeah
I was I wasn't as svelte in the uniform
as I thought I was when I watched some
of the footage but I we had a good time
because you do anything
yes modern era and somebody gets upset
John Madden wasn't right happy with you
John Madden and this is real John Madden
got mad yes he heard that you were doing
this and I guess he saw you playing
these differences you know teams in
spring Britain spring ball and he said I
hate it lack of respect for the game and
for what players have to do to get where
they are right where did that come from
I don't think he got all the pieces of
information yeah I well first of all
he's right look at me I'm all about lack
of respect yeah I don't think the
interviewer told him it was all for
charity number one but I do love that in
his mind he just thought I was like
Major League Baseball I want to play in
in ten ten different games for ten
different teams I want to do it Thursday
because I'm a big shot Willy Wonka yeah
so that's what we do like just will
ferrell just thinks you can insert
himself right into big league games
so have you gonna speak to mr. Madden
are you gonna - no but my next thing I
want to do for charity is I'm going to
impersonate football analyst
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so look out look out honey honey em when
he played it up was laid on him we
played the baseball games you didn't
have anyone on your shoulder did you I
don't know what you're talking okay
you